When we analyzed a
one-dimensional elastic
collision in any
frame and we had
a velocity V1 initial
and V2 initial,
that we saw that
we could reduce--
this is a one-dimensional
elastic collision--
we always have the energy
condition and the momentum
condition.
But when we combine the
energy movement together,
we found the following idea
that the relative velocity
V1, 2, which we called the
relative velocity initial,
was just equal to the
final relative velocity.
The statement there was
that V1 initial minus V2
initial is equal to minus
V1 final minus V2 final.
And we call this the
energy momentum relation
for our classical mechanics.
And then we could combine that
with our conservation of energy
law, conservation of momentum.
And we've got a linear
system of equations
that is much easier to solve
than the quadratic system.
Now what I'd like to
show is that this concept
of relative velocity, that
V1, 2 relative velocity
is independent of the
choice of reference frame.
And so if we want to
analyze a collision
in any other reference
frame, then we always
can keep this result. So
now let's look at that.
So again, let's imagine that
we have two particles, where we
have particle 1 and particle 2.
We have some origin, r1 and r2.
And now we want to choose
another reference frame.
So suppose that we pick a second
reference frame, which has
maybe some origin over here.
And we have the vectors
r1 prime and r2 prime.
And the relative vector from
the center of one reference
frame to the center of
the other reference frame.
So what we have are
the two conditions
that r1 is equal to
capital R plus r1 prime.
r1 is capital R plus r1 prime.
r2 is capital R plus r2 prime.
And now if we subtract
these two equations,
we have r1 minus r2 equals
r1 prime minus r2 prime.
And this shows us that
the relative position
vectors-- and let's draw
that this one from 2 to 1.
And even in our diagram, we can
see that the vector from 2 to 1
does not depend on the
choice of reference frame.
And even more importantly,
when we differentiate,
we get that V1 minus V2 is equal
to V1 prime minus V2 prime.
And that becomes our statement
that the relative velocity
vector is independent of the
choice of reference frame.